look at that folks in Charlotte North
Carolina who are walking into the end of
vote this morning in today's Super
Tuesday primary Democrats and
Republicans believe the state will be a
potential battleground in November
President Trump held a rally there last
night looking to win North Carolina
again this year Democrats hoped that new
voters will flip the state which has
voted Republican in every recent
presidential election except 2008 chip
Reed is in Charlotte chip why is North
Carolina changing well I tell you North
Carolina is one of the fastest-growing
states in the country and most of that
growth is happening in cities like
Charlotte and most of those people who
are pouring in here tend to be younger
and more diverse and that has Democrats
feeling pretty hopeful offices like this
one reflect the changing face of North
Carolina founded 10 years ago in the
basement of an abandoned cigarette
factory American underground now has
five locations with a mission to help
new businesses take off which is really
the launch spot Mollie Demarest grew up
here in Durham and now manages this
campus for startups would it be accurate
to call this area a magnet for young
high-tech oriented people absolutely and
was it that way when you were growing up
not from what I remember American
underground is part of statewide growth
that seen nearly 300,000 jobs created
and more than 1 million new registered
voters since the last presidential
election there's a draw of people from
out of market and then there's also a
lot of people that are choosing to stay
you know the brain drain concept I think
we're seeing that less and less
hospitality is the state's fastest
growing sector spurred in part by a
craft beer boom that seen breweries
skyrocket from just a few dozen in 2011
to more than 300 today I am the black
woman in North Carolina
Brianna break launched space way brewing
in 2018 she and fellow entrepreneur
Nicole Oxendine here would like
politicians to talk more about barriers
for women of color
there are ceilings for black women I
think
you know it ripples into so many
different layers of life but no I was
talking about that I like the people
that say the most radical things Bernie
Sanders are saying some stuff that it's
like but he's got my mom like how's this
man gonna do all this stuff there's no
way he can but I'm like well shouldn't
you go with the dude and Fair woman or
whoever they're saying the most broadest
thing maybe you'll get some of that a
political battleground president Trump
one Nash County by fewer than 100 votes
in 2016 but breaks operation inside this
old Confederate cotton mill shows the
area is changing people come out to me
and say you're here so everything is
good now like y'all don't have anything
to complain about
basically and I'm like please let's just
drink this beer and not have this
conversation people have been here for
years they've been doing it and that's
black and white leave been doing it our
way for years and years you know how can
we as the next generation kind of pulls
together and say well we want something
different our vision of hope the same
year President Trump won in North
Carolina finally the state elected
Democrat Rory Cooper as governor do you
believe that North Carolina is moving
from being a red state to a blue state
definitely no doubt about it Trey Knicks
ran Cooper's campaign I think the state
is way more competitive today than
people totally realize and I think now
that you've got so much growth there
will be a day where Republicans will not
win here very much outside the city
farmers are struggling and tobacco once
the state's most profitable crop has
seen sales to its largest trading
partner China plummet from 166 million
dollars in 2016 to just over 1 million
dollars last year
I keep hearing Secretary of Agriculture
and other folks say you know short-term
pain for long-term gain but you got to
survive that short-term pain or the
long-term gain doesn't do you any good
farmer Brandon batten cut his tobacco
production in half losing hundreds of
thousands of dollars in revenue but he
remains optimistic and supportive of
President Trump I think he needs a
little more time it didn't get this way
overnight and I don't know that's not
gonna be fixed overnight but I'm hopeful
that you know the president's right and
we'll need better tractors and more land
but I haven't
yes we talked to nearly a dozen farmers
here in North Carolina who are hoping
new trade deals will help turn things
around and for the most part they're
sticking by president Trump but here in
the cities Democrats are confident the
political tide is turning in their
direction Jim that's a great piece a
million new voters registered 2016
that's what stands out to me yeah that's
a lot of people all right Jim thank you
very much